So the correct answer is this one. The percent of faces correctly recognized and
placed from parts I and II. So this is very precise, the percent of faces. The
others contribute to your score so if you remember specific types of faces, that
helps you to get a higher percentage. Or knowing whether you saw the face first
or second? That also helps you get a better score, but that's not how it was
measured. Knowing whether or not the face was there? Yes, that contributes to
your score. And the tricky one, the number of faces you remember. If the score
were given to you as a number For example, you remembered, I dunno 11 out of 12,
that would be the way that BBC measured it but your score at the end was a
percent. So this is how they measure memory. And it's important to be very
precise. And if you got that wrong, don't worry. This was a tricky question and
it's more just to get you thinking.